on the next Rick and Morty turn myself
into a pickle Morty I'm just trying to
figure out why you would do this why
anyone would do this
the reason anyone would do this if they
could which they can would be because
they could which they can't is this the
first part of some kind of magic trick I
don't do magic Morty I do science one
takes brains gonna take dark eyeliner
can show you episode of Rick and Morty
Sunday at 11:30 - pickles live forever
already stop digging for hidden layers
and just be impressed
[Music]
pickle Rick this can only end with one
of us dead and I have never died it'll
be your downfall jagwire not being open
to new experiences
Rick and Morty's all-new episodes begin
Sunday July 30th at 11:30 pickle Rick
let's break this down so this is next
week's episode it's probably going to be
one of the best ones all season long
it's a crazy twist Rick turns himself
into a pickle and it's sort of a
Breaking Bad omage of how he has to get
himself out of this impossible situation
he's literally a pickle with no arms or
legs that falls into the sewer it has to
escape so that's what the second part of
this clip is all about but if you guys
are big breaking bad bands they've been
using Walt being stuck in the RV and
having to work himself out of an
impossible situation is a reference for
Rick's journey in this episode so if you
don't remember that it was Breaking Bad
season 3 episode 6 they were trying to
get rid of the RV to get rid of the
evidence it was the beginning of the
super lap it was the first episode that
I think we met Gail and where he had
that Walt Whitman quotes we might hear
some Walt Whitman Leaves of Grass jokes
in the episode but he finds out that
hank has been tailing Jesse so he comes
to the junkyard and they're sitting
there in the RV oh my god what the hell
do we do this is a little clip from that
ya got
the same we need your help so in the way
that they did Mad Max for the first
episode you can see they're not going to
do an exact copy of the breaking bad
episode it's just a trick their version
of Heisenberg has to MacGyver himself
using all of his knowledge and science
to get out of this situation so you see
all these trailer scenes with him just
sawing through all of these mice he
steals one of their brains and fashions
this Iron Man harness to fly out of the
drain there isn't a lot of context for
the second part of that clip but as you
see Rick dominating as pickle Rick like
there's no situation he can't get
himself out of Yuri watched that
Breaking Bad clip how did Walt get him
and Jesse out of that situation even
though he's this towering genius that
created the crystal blue and has been
outsmarting the law enforcement agencies
left and right he breaks down in when
Jesse says tell me you got something to
get us out of this he says yeah I got
something any calls solve and says we
need some help so it's his way of saying
that even though he's the smartest
person on the show he's a genius there
are some things that he can't do by
himself he's not completely invincible
so that is a bit of a hat tip for what
might be happening in the episode where
Rick goes through this tour de force of
getting himself out of the terrain he
turns into this crazy Frankenstein's
monster pickle but he's probably going
to have to ask someone like Morty or
someone else to help get himself out of
the pickle that he's got himself into
the metaphorical pickle and the literal
pickle but the cool thing about this is
that in that breaking bad episode there
were a couple other big things going on
that are also happening on Rick and
Morty right now Skyler was trying to
divorce Walt she has these papers that
he needs to sign obviously Beth and
Jerry are getting divorced we haven't
seen them officially signed papers so
they had to follow up on that plotline
that's one of the few big serialized
stories this season you still have the
Galactic government you have Phoenix
person hopefully they'll bring them back
hopefully that wasn't just a one-off
funny thing at the end of that episode
but really the heaviest
they're continuing is that divorce just
with the status of the family them
trying to deal without Gerry in him
being all sad lonely with the
prostitutes outside his hotel room
oh so that's what they are but I do love
the idea that Marty is kind of their
version of Jesse just a little too dumb
for his own good but has a couple really
good moments while he's busy stepping on
the toes of Rick's big plans don't get
in the way in my genius Marty and even
though Walt cares about Jesse he's just
as disposable to him as Marty and summer
are to Rick summer hold on I want to try
something Rick can we not leave without
my sister ah you have infinite sisters
Morty I mean not that I want to spend
the rest of my day looking for another
one sometimes let's go grab us concern
for your safety is fleeting but I know
everybody has a whole bunch of theories
about evil Morty in the robots from
episode 2 maybe one of them gained
sentience at some point so I will do a
Rick and Morty Theory video later this
week and I know a lot of you were
wondering if the person that our methey
was trying to get revenge against
strangling in the tub was meant to be a
reference to Joffrey on Game of Thrones
he's my genitals again can't wash out
and you'll be shipped to the waistband
and as for you genital washer
Oh God look whoever you are if your nose
killing me won't change it then look man
I'm just along for the ride on this one
you know you preaching to the choir here
please slavery was a family business I
didn't ask to be born into it nobody
think hide the victim here
that wasn't my immediate take away but
his hair looks a little similar and you
could say the way he speaks is a little
bit like Joffrey and it is kind of weird
that there's a full-blown medieval
castle in this post-apocalyptic Mad Max
wasteland like where did this castle
come from and why is everybody else
living like this but Rick and Morty draw
from all over pop culture for their
references so you get a lot of sci-fi
and fantasy in the same episode that's
one of the things that makes it so
awesome in fun fact in real life the
place where Dan Harmon's production
company's starburns industry lives is in
something that they call the starburns
Castle is a building in Burbank that's
made to look like an actual castle
that's where they do a lot of their
harmontown
maybe they'll do more live stuff like
they did earlier this year with the live
episode but leave all your requests for
bonus videos in the comments below
obviously the new episode is going to
air on Sunday so my video for it will
post early Monday morning just like I
did this week and I'm still doing that
weekly merch giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video but they'll
probably drop another promo later this
week so whatever ends up happening I'll
totally do a video for it
congratulations to the latest merch
giveaway winner Anthony Guzman please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for everything
you can click here for my episode 2
Easter eggs and references video and you
can click here for all my other Rick and
Morty season 3 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]